bon je vais être franc si tu acceptes de
me donner quelques leçons de danse tu le
sauvera littéralement la vie voilà je
pige pas c'était vraiment dans un
spectacle comment ça se fait que tu as
pas de chorégraphes jandilla seulement
sa gran maladie perche où et comment je
peux savoir que toi t'es pas chez lui
comment je peux savoir si tu est réglo à
viens avec moi une répétition tu verras
wouah où tu crois quoi que je vais
suivre un type que je connais même pas
une répétition sinon comment je peux te
prouver que le chéri de l'eau
[Musique]
je le savais que tu étais chelou
c'est bon j'ai limité quelqu'un a vu
mademoiselle trop les tient pour toi
johnny c'est au sûrement oui voila je
suis désolé mais j'ai bien réfléchi moi
j'ai des doutes pour ce projet couet
diminuera les derniers rappels on va
partir une seconde on arrive je m'y a
raison c'est vrai cette découvreuse de
talents elle nous a pas trouvé assez bon
elle m'a l'air d'une grosse cruche là
une cause colossal oui et elle a tort
totalement il ya une bonne raison pour
que notre choix affiche complet tous les
soirs et moi je vous le dit son patron
va adorer ou ou alors peut-être on
pourrait monter un spectacle un peu
différent vous voyez winter s'il te
plaît c'est moi qui gère sérieux j'ai
une super idée pour une comédie musicale
de l'espace français attendu on est
parti vous ne pas comprendre de la
comédie musicale de l'espace
c
[Musique]
écoutez les amis j'ai toujours rêvé de
me produire arrête jar city depuis que
je suis toute petite et en plus j'ai
convaincu mon mari de jouer les baby
sitter pour les prochaines 24 heures
alors je vais pas cacher une telle
opportunité comme ça monte on n'a rien à
perdre tout à gagner